Aunque el Porto no ha hecho precisamente un gran Mundial de Clubs, más bien al contrario,
ha dado cosita a verle, en sus filas tiene un pequeño gran genio que ha sido de lo más
destacado de su campeonato. Se llama Rodrigo Mora, es del 2007, gran añada y mola mucho verle jugar.
Tenemos que deciros, que ya llevábamos varios meses con ganas de hablar de Rodrigo Mora,
no habíamos encontrado el momento hasta ahora, hasta esta fecha, justo tras la eliminación del
Porto en el Mundial de Clubs, pero también justo antes de que se pueda mover en el mercado de
fichajes, porque estoy convencido que muchos clubes no, porque que le puedan fichar hay
pocos, pero dentro de esos 10 clubes el 80% tiene que tener el nombre de Rodrigo Mora,
su rayada en amarillo, porque es ese tipo de genio por el que hay que apostar ahora,
porque si no apuestas ahora y la apuesta sale buena, salvo cosas raras, no le puedes fichar.
Yo he de decir una cosa y lo digo ya, para ya destaparnos las cartas. No te gusta Rodrigo Mora.
No me entusiasma Rodrigo Mora, he de decir que además para el tipo de equipo que creo que
económicamente se puede permitir su fichaje, PSG sería su mejor destino yo creo, pero Premier
League me cuesta. Porque es pequeñito ¿no? No porque sea pequeñito, que yo creo que al final
un jugador pequeñito David Silva la premisa adaptó fácilmente. Claro, o sea me parece que le falta
algo de motor cuando sale del regate. Bueno, menos mal que no es una carrera de fórmula 1. Estoy de
acuerdo, ahora vamos a hablar de las cosas de Rodrigo Mora, pero me bajas el sufle antes de
haber mezclado los ingredientes. Espérate, yo he presentado un pequeño disclaimer que la gente
debe conocer. Bueno, lo importante. Aquí todos sois muy Rodrigo Moristas. A mí me ha gustado menos
en la revisión que en los highlights, gustándome mucho. Mira, pero eso es algo normal ¿no? No,
porque con Franco Mastanto no me pasó al revés, que era una diferencia que quería hacer. O sea,
yo a Franco Mastanto no le había visto y solo los highlights y bien, muy bien, pero tal, pero luego
le di jugar y me encantó más. Sin embargo, Rodrigo Mora, o sea Mastanto es más guapo en persona ¿no?
Muy bien tirada. Sí, sí, gana en directo. Y sin embargo, Rodrigo Mora es muy fotogénico,
se saca partido en el perfil. Dicho lo cual, me parece que es un jugador del que tenemos que hablar
y por eso estamos aquí, porque para empezar ha tenido un impacto estelar en el Porto, que es un
equipo que como luego vamos a comentar, no le da nada a Rodrigo Mora. No, es verdad, y el impacto
ha sido en cuestión de meses, porque él debuta en el mes de septiembre y pierde el primero en
Europa League y después en Liga, aún con Víctor Bruno en el banquillo del Porto, marca su primer
goal en la Liga portuguesa a finales del mes de octubre y no es hasta mediados de diciembre,
diciembre de 2024, hace nada, cuando empieza a entrar ya con regularidad como titular en los
planes del Porto. Es un camino bastante parecido al de João Félix en aquel año de la explosión con
el Benziga, solo que en el caso de João hizo más cifras e hizo una web Europa League más resultona
para que el Atlético de Madrid paga esos 127 millones porque formó parte del club de los engañados
por João Félix como servidor. No ha pasado desapercibido el impacto que ha tenido en el
Porto, ya ha ido convocado con Portugal Nations, no llegó a debutar con Roberto Martínez, pero
bueno, ya estaba en la convocatoria de la Nations League y es un jugador que en la Youth League con
el Porto en la temporada 23-24 hace siete goles, nueve partidos, es decir, que venía pisando fuerte
ya en las categorías inferiores del Porto. Es uno de esos jugadores a los que ves llegar.
Claro, y ha conseguido trasladar ese rendimiento que tienen las categorías inferiores al primer
equipo de un Porto que ahora vamos a analizar como tú decías Quintana, que no le da nada,
absolutamente nada. Diez goles, cuatro asistencias también comentaba que pertenece a una gran añada,
la del 2007, siempre recordamos la del 87, que es la de Leo Messi, Luis Suárez, el Kun, Gonzalo
Higuain, Gerard Piquet, Cesc Fábregas, esa gran generación del Barça, pero aparte hay muchos
jugadores también en el mundo. Claro, en 2007 han nacido Lamín Llaval, Pau Cubarsí, Franco Mastantuono,
Esteban, Kendri Páez y Rodrigo Mora. Cuidado, alguno de estos se caerá. De hecho, lo más normal es
que dos o tres no lleguen a ser lo que prometen ahora porque si no es que prometen ser de estos
cinco de los diez mejores jugadores del mundo. Pero mamma mía. Sí, sí, telita con lo que se viene con
esta generación, dos de ellos españoles. Dos de ellos españoles, exactamente. Dos carnes de selección
absoluta para muchos años. Y a otros ya lo vamos a ver aquí en la Liga Española como es el caso de
Franco Mastantuono. Rodrigo Mora es un mediapunta, aunque en el sistema de Anselmi ha jugado de
media punta, pero una media punta de dos. Sí, doble media punta. Exactamente lo que tiene que hacer
a veces con Fabio Vieira, lo hemos visto en el Mundial de Clubes con Gabriel Veiga. Bueno, ha ido
alternando ahí Anselmi, pero la clave es que es un futbolista de jugar entre líneas con un giro muy
rápido y siempre con vocación de acelerar. Sí, incluso en el Mundial de Clubes hemos visto cómo
segundo punta por detrás de Samu. Sí. Con quien me cuentan que tiene una gran relación. Mira,
pues es importante para que mezquen bien. Claro, es que Mora tiene las letras de amor, entonces es
fácil yo a ese momento. Mira, ya la has soltado. Sí, la habías pensado desde el principio y dices…
A ver, cuéntale a la cual. Hay un sketch muy famoso de José María Listorti que no lo conocéis,
pero yo os recomiendo que lo veáis. Estoy aquí yo recomendando dos cosas… Que luego os caen en saco
roto, ¿no? Sí, sí, sí. Pero bueno, yo os recomiendo mucho a José María Listorti que tiene un sketch con
esto. Ahora lo veo. Tú ves. La falta de respeto es tremenda. Es como eres complicado como amigo,
Miguel, tío. No nos hace caso. Estoy aquí yo como recomendando de cosas como Rufián a Vito Quiles y
tú sudando. Pues como Rufián de Vito Quiles. Total. Sí, a ver, es un juego que destaca por la calidad.
De estos jugadores es que uno ve y entra rápido por el off. Sí, muy suave. Porque lo ves es diferente,
es especial. Es un juego con mucho talento, con mucha habilidad técnica, que gira muy bien
cuando recibe de espaldas, que sabe proteger muy bien la pelota. Un poco peonza. A veces gira un
poco de más, ¿no? Sí, pero como no tiene la velocidad punta, que antes destacaba Álex porque
no tiene una gran zancada, al ser pequeñito… Es verdad que la utiliza como recurso. Es que gira
una vez, inicia la conducción, como ve que no se va a imponer, gira otra vez. Gira otra vez y le
hacen la falta. Muchas veces consigue sacar así y rascar faltas para darle metros al porto. Me parece
un jugador bastante ingenioso en el tercer final del campo. Es un jugador que va bastante lanzado
porque cuando recibe en zona de tres cuartos no da un pase de más, sino que rápidamente levanta
la cabeza y si puede filtrar el paseo, filtra y si puede buscar por terreno, mejor. Porque luego…
El gol al Agli, por ejemplo. Sí, eso es. Y ahí es verdad que se vieron parte de sus cualidades,
¿no? Tanto del giro como del movimiento rápido de pies y luego, sobre todo, bastante facilidad
para encontrar el gol, que creo que es lo más sorprendente en esta temporada. Me gusta que
destaque es lo de velocidad de pies porque es verdad. O sea, es verdad que no es un jugador
súper potente y que encima, como es liviano, cada vez que va el choque palma, claro. Sí, es que…
Pero es muy rápido de pies. O sea, es un futbolista que en esos espacios reducidos es capaz de tocar
varias veces la pelota o de cambiar de dirección antes de que el defensa haya elegido por dónde ir.
Es un metro sesenta y ocho, Rodrigo Morá. Que a la misma altura de Messi. Ah, pues mira, seguramente
será más veloz de mente para salir de esas situaciones, imaginar rápido dónde puede estar
la solución porque en el choque es verdad que sufre. Y no os sorprende, chicos, que hablando de
Rodrigo Morá, como estamos hablando, me apunta imaginativo, resolutivo… El perfil izquierdo siempre.
Sí, el perfil izquierdo, resolutivo, etcétera. … y lo hace dentro. ¿Sea más goleador que asistente?
O sea, porque el perfil Rodrigo Morá… No tiene mucho que ver aquí el equipo. Estoy de acuerdo,
el perfil Rodrigo Morá te lleva a que sea ese futbolista genial que te filtra balones. Es
Martíno de Garport, por citar un ejemplo. Sí. Pues es que aquí mi sensación es que está
condicionado por el equipo porque muchas veces es que tiene que bajar a recibir muy abajo. Sí, sí.
Demasiado. Porque el Porto ha echado mucho de menos a Nico González. Y luego tiene que trasladar la
pelota arriba porque también perdió a Wondersong Galeno al comienzo del año. Cierto. Que era ese
jugador de conducción, de desborde… Differencial, sí, sí. … que te añadía un poquito. Y es que
muchas jugadas tienen que ser alfa y omega de la jugada mora. Sí. Y no porque sea exactamente un
chupón que algo de chupón tiene. Un típico crack que cuando sube… Claro. Todos estos chicos
que hemos dicho… A veces se demora, ¿no? … más tanto, no. La mía más y demás tiene un poquito
de chupones porque es normal. Pero es que si no… No tiene con quién mezclar. Una. Porque sabemos que
además Samu no es ese jugador con el que mezclar. A Samu le puedes lanzar, pero tampoco es ese jugador
con el que vayas a tirar una pared. Preparando su análisis he mirado algún dato y me ha sorprendido
que es el segundo jugador de la Liga portuguesa que más diferencia tiene respecto a los expected
goals con sus goles. Es decir, que ha sobremarcado… Son más efectivos, diríamos. Sí. Sí, algo así.
Sí. Pero es que es una barbaridad. ¿Cuánto? Más 5,3. O sea, tendría que haber marcado alrededor
de 4 o 5 goles y ha marcado 10. Claro, el primero es Jokeres, que esto es una barbaridad. Porque
Jokeres ha marcado… Tendría que haber marcado 30… Perdón, tendría que haber marcado 21 y ha marcado 39.
Esto puede ser una red flag si no logra mantenerlo, porque no tengo el dato. Pero estoy bastante
convencido de que Joao Félix, aquella temporada con el Benfica, también sobremarcó. También estuvo por encima.
De hecho, Joao Félix a lo largo del tiempo, mira, creo que lo va a buscar a veces, no ha podido
mantener ese instinto. Pero a mí el Joao Félix del Benfica, yo recuerdo… Además, lo bueno es que están
los vídeos ahí en YouTube, así que me los podéis sacar. Yo recuerdo que se comparaba mucho con Kaká
por el tema del pelito y yo le dije que no es Kaká, es un jugador de último tercio. A mí me
ha recordado en cosas a Raúl. Le veía el instinto que tenía Raúl González Blanco. Luego, igual es el
jugador más diferente a Raúl González Blanco. Pero que tenía esa sensación de llegar porque es verdad
que es un jugador que pisa mucho a área. No es solo jugador de recibimiento de los cuartos, sino que llega
mucho a la área. Más 5,2. Pues ahí está. Marcó 15 goles y tendría que haber marcado 9 o 10. ¿Y cuánto
mide Joao Félix? Pues 1,80. Sí, sí, sí. Más alto. Sí, sí, más alto. Hay una cualidad que me gusta
mucho de su fútbol antes de pasar en lo que no le está dando el Porto a Rodrigo Mora, que es la calidad
que tiene en el espacio reducido. Cuando le meten el pie, que van a meterle siempre el pie, conseguí
salir de muchas situaciones, sobre todo a través de ese giro donde parece imposible que vaya a salir
y consiga hacerlo. Muy talentoso. Sí, sí. A ver, ¿por qué no decimos primero lo que le da el Porto a
Rodrigo Mora y luego vamos a lo siguiente? Porque yo creo que lo único que le da el Porto a
Rodrigo Mora es galones para jugarse. La titularidad, ¿no? Y luego libertad para jugarse. Eso es
verdad que la tiene. Pero ya está. Sí, sí. No le dan un pase limpio, no hay desborde por banda
porque los dos carreros, Maura y tal, que es el de su lado. Es verdad que como decíamos en el caso
de Mastantuno con River, ha encontrado a Rodrigo Mora en el Porto un equipo que confía en él como
el crack. Le da la pelota muchas veces muy lejos de la portería, le dice, inventa tú, porque nos
tomamos el incapacidad de ponerte cerca del área muchas situaciones en ventaja para que saques tu
mejor fútbol. Esto claro, habrá que verlo y habrá que trasladarlo cuando Rodrigo Mora dé el salto
a tu equipo. Y no se la pueda fumar siempre. Efectivamente. Y no puedo tener ese mismo rol,
pero es que estamos viendo en Rodrigo Mora que recibe muchas veces por detrás incluso de la línea
a medio campo. O sea, que baja muy abajo, pero muy abajo a recibir porque el Porto está sufriendo tal
atasco a nivel de juego que tiene dos soluciones. O el balón a Mora en el círculo central o el
pelotazo a Samu para que Samu lo baje y se apañe él. Yo creo que esto habla de su personalidad,
que está bien que la tenga un jugador que no se esconda, Nahuel, pero es verdad que hace difícil
la proyección. Porque cuando ya estás en un Porto, sabes que sólo puedes ir a un candidato
de ganar Copa de Europa. Y ese candidato de ganar de Copa de Europa no te va a dar esos galones.
De esta lista rápida que hemos dicho, el Madrid no le va a dar a Franco Mastantuno los galones para
que se ha jugado todo. Estebao no lo va a tener en el Chelsea, como no lo va a tener el Cheverri en
el City. El único que los tiene es la Mignamal. Y primero, porque parece el mejor de todos. Y digo
parece porque acaban de empezar los chavales. Y segundo, porque se lo ha ganado ya en el propio
Barça, no en otro equipo. Y cuando hablabas antes de posibles destinos y equipos que puedan pagar,
la clausura son 70. Ya sabemos que no es el oportuno de esos clubes que esté muy abierto
a negociar para bajarla. No está ya pintada a costa, pero André Villas-Boas no tiene pinta de
hacer regates. El tema es, claro, para construir desde la nada, que te habló por todo. Todos los
entrenadores en cantera que ha tenido Rodrigo Mora y que salen en los diferentes reportajes,
que suelen salir cuando brilla un crack como lo hace él, te hablan de la inteligencia táctica,
de saber dónde tiene que aparecer. Un poquito al estilo de lo que hace Dani Olmo, de tener
muy controlados los espacios donde tiene que aparecer. Claro, si tu margen de acción es el que tú quieras,
porque el equipo es un desastre, yo estoy de acuerdo que cuesta calibrar hasta qué punto puede
ser importante de Rodrigo Mora entrando menos en juego con el balón. En un precisamente contexto
en el que yo creo que él tiene dos situaciones favorables. Uno, precisamente esa libertad que
le permite el Oporto, esa facilidad que le permite también para recibir el balón, para jugarse muchas
de ellas. Pero que yo creo que además se ha encontrado en este Porto tan ausente de jugadores
que puedan destacar, tan ausente de futbolistas en los que se pueda confiar que él ha aprovechado
ese hueco y que yo creo que lo ha hecho verdaderamente bien y a nivel probablemente...
No le puedes pedir, en clave, en Oporto no le puedes pedir más.
A Rodrigo Mora no se puede pedir nada más. O sea, Rodrigo Mora ha estado perfecto esta temporada y
dentro de lo que son sus cualidades, dentro de lo que es el contexto, dentro de lo que es el propio
Oporto que ha sufrido tantos cambios que al final yo creo que ha terminado perdiendo cierta identidad,
pues se ha encontrado un talento así que bueno yo entiendo que seguirá una temporada más en el
Oporto precisamente, pero sí que me parece que obviamente el fútbol portugués suele vender caro,
que es verdad que las últimas ventas hay que echarle un ojo porque creo que... te diría que
la Enzo Fernández es la única, pero las últimas han salido un poco de aquella manera.
O sea, los Ramos también.
Habrá que ver cómo termina de salir Jokeres y cómo es su impacto en otro club,
pero yo creo que ya se está empezando a perder un poco la... cómo diríamos... la visión de que un
futbolista, me lo invento, de liga portuguesa sea capaz de trasladar su rendimiento a premio.
A lo que va a ser que durante una década futbolista que salía de Portugal, Radamel Falcao, Ángel Di
María, hay muchos ejemplos, salían muy bien. Equipo con Pepe defiende mejor.
Ya la está costando. Obviamente van a vender caro.
Acceden a peores perfiles. Porque esto lo hemos dicho siempre con el fútbol portugués,
lo hemos hablado mucho con Miguel Pereira, que antes el fútbol portugués era un poco
como lo del Villarreal con Sudamérica. Estaba tan poquito explotado el ir y traer a ciertos jugadores
que asumíamos que los sudamericanos muchas veces pasaban por Portugal y luego ya les fichaban.
De hecho, por ejemplo, los perfiles que... hay un perfil que fichaba en FICA que es
Prestiani. Sí.
Un chico muy habilidoso, pero que llega con la tana de decir que este chico fuera del
terreno de juego cuidado y hay que un poquito aterrizarlo.
No son ni las primeras opciones, rollo Estebado, más tanto.
Sí, no estás echando un Echeverry. Ni muchas veces las segundas.
Pégate, te voy a cantar las ventas récord de fútbol portugués. Yo a Félix, Enzo, Darwin,
podríamos quedarnos ahí, pero Rubén Díaz bien, Gonzalo Ramos, Bruno Fernández bien,
Tito, hay que verlo, Ogarte, hay que seguir viéndolo, Octavio, Sefal Naser, Joan Eves.
No has dicho nada de... de Ogarte. Bueno, aunque lo he dicho.
Mi hermano Ogarte. De verdad, me llevo bien con él.
No, de verdad no. Literalmente no.
O sea, el sentido literal. Desangreno.
Dijo el escuchador otro día, le he dicho a Lizy que le revienta cuando la gente se llama
de hermano. Ah, sí?
Que le da mucho valor a la familia y que hermano es una palabra que se le gusta.
También Lizy un poquito se la coge con papel.
Sí. Bueno, que le escucha mucho el vestuario.
Ya, de verdad. Yo le doy valor a la amistad.
Lo peor es lo del bro. Lo del bro sí que te oye.
A mí me escucha mucho en el vestuario lo de que hay que sacar a la morocha y me imagino
que su mujer estará... Bueno, no sé si está Lizy casada, la verdad.
¿Hemos tenido al look rap por aquí? Sí, por locha.
Hemos tenido al look rap por aquí.
¿Ah, sí? ¿Cuándo?
Te lo has cruzado. ¿En serio?
Sí. Bueno, estaba otra cosa.
Bueno, eh... Pero literalmente se lo has cruzado.
¿Liberalmente me lo has cruzado? Ostras.
Ah, ¿sí?
Sí. No, no hay mucho.
No se maneja. Ha sido un poquito flow young kouto.
No, back in the day.
Ninja, ¿no? ¿Quieres decir algo?
Eh... No, a ver, que es un...
Es que yo creo que podemos abrir un poco la puerta
de los defectos de futbolistas.
Sí. Que da la sensación de que...
Aspectos a mejorar. Sí.
Yo creo que no es un jugador que lo ves tres partidos
y dices, oye,
voy a soltar todo porque creo que hay,
como decía antes Álex, ciertas dudas de
hasta qué punto, por ejemplo, al físico le puede la extrapar a mal.
Claro. Ese me parece el primer punto.
A nivel físico es un jugador que tiene que desarrollarse todavía.
Pero él no se va a desarrollar, ¿no?
O sea, quiero decir... Antes decíamos lo de Messi.
No, no, pero crecer un poco, al menos.
Chocar con Messi era muy complicado. Claro.
Es que a Messi siempre se... Yo he leído
veces opiniones de Messi ha sido lo que ha sido
a pesar del físico. No, no, no. A ver.
Messi ha sido lo que ha sido en parte
gracias también al físico que era perfecto
para él. Claro.
Fuerte de tronco. Los muslos.
A veces no se habla de la fortaleza
en el tren superior, que es clave
porque una diferencia muy evidente
entre el fútbol profesional
y el fútbol amateur... Échame el suelo a mí.
Tírame. Inténtalo. Es el tema de cómo
se usan los brazos y cómo se usa
el contacto. Sí, sí.
Ahí lo necesitas y luego tenía una capacidad
para girar de dirección,
incluso para hacer una tontería, unos
tobillos laxos para no haber fallecido.
Ulfaluci.
Directamente lo Vicente Calderón.
Que cuidado. Necesita Rodrigo Mora
un veranito con Pedri. Sí.
Sentad y apulgará.
Ir a ver leones, ¿no?
Es verdad que
como el Porto está en el caos
es difícil ponderar
lo que estamos destacando
en él. Creo que tiene que mejorar,
como decimos de todo joven, la toma de decisiones.
Tú lo decías antes.
Es que el Porto le da
tantísima responsabilidad que él dice
perfecto, yo me la fumo. Claro.
Pécala individualista en el tercer final del campo.
Intenta muchas veces. En acciones que no toca.
Esa jugada que habéis visto en los highlights
que marcó un golazo, la intenta muchas veces.
Pero aquí vuelvo a decir que
creo que tiene que ver con que no…
Que no hay más. Que la hace él o él.
No hay más que la quedar. Efectivamente.
Y luego un punto a… Y se le ha quedado una broma.
No, ya no entra.
No, no. Iba muy al palo
y cuando he visto… Como es estornudo,
que está ahí y no sale.
Que te empieza a picar la delirio.
Y luego algo que sí,
creo que no va a poder mejorar
porque ha nacido así, con esa punta de velocidad.
No sé hasta qué punto lo va a poder desarrollar.
No es ultra potente. Claro.
El tema del Leo Messi.
Leo Messi tiene una potencia.
Creo que como decía antes Álex, le va a limitar
un poco el salto que pueda tener de cara al futuro.
Al menos el salto más inmediato.
Para mí es mi duda. Sí, porque es un jugador
que… Quiero decirte,
no es ese futbolista
de tocar rápido,
de jugar a uno o dos toques.
Es un jugador que absorbe mucho protagonismo,
que absorbe… O sea, que acapara muchas marcas.
Y tiene mucho balón. Claro.
Tiene mucho contacto con el balón. Yo con esto,
los 70 de la cláusula, por ejemplo, no los pago.
Es una limitación
que me parece importante para super, super
élite, que es de lo que estamos hablando.
Claro. Por eso le estamos analizando
aquí que también hemos hecho a veces análisis
de jugadores que también tenían alguna contraindicación
o que no han funcionado. Ojalá nos equivoquemos.
Hoylun Remember.
Ojalá nos equivoquemos porque es un futbolista
con talento.
Y creo que el futbolista con talento…
Y bonito de ver. Y bonito de ver
que muchas veces no termina
en el paso. Por eso tiene ese reto.
Por eso nos encaja más en Liga o Serie A que en Premi.
Por el ritmo, sí. Que es un poquito siempre
el biotipo típico
pero que tiene mucho de cierto.
Ojo, que aquí siempre descartamos la Bundesliga,
que es verdad que tiene grandes físicos, pero hay grandes espacios.
Sí. Por el ritmo que
tiene él jugando, me encajaría
en Liga o Serie A. El tema es que creo que la Serie A
ahora mismo no está preparada para realizar un fichaje
así de 70.000 euros. La Juve.
Como mucho. Que podría ser.
La Juve en algún momento de…
Y tiene a Gilded que, por ejemplo,
en el Gilded Mora, a mí apuntan a Gilded.
No, claro. Y, además,
por lo barato que le salió, que él se lo fichó por un millón
al Bayern en un momento de cantera…
Sí. Hayan compensado la liada con Haussens.
Sí, tal cual. La gaila que tal.
Y lo bien que les ha salido con Seizao.
O por lo menos lo bien que está
redirigiendo el tema con Seizao.
Que es otro chico bajito que ha salido de Portugal
pero muy diferente. Para mí muy potente.
Es un cabestro.
Se nota que es hijo de un auténtico
cacirao del fútbol como Sergio con Seizao.
El quiasa portugués.
Y en España solo podrían encajar
en dos equipos que tienen que ver
ellos si Rodrigo Mora es realmente tan bueno
como para hacer esta inversión de 70 kilos.
Porque yo creo que igual el tercero
está diciendo yo. Están dando
sudores fríos portugués.
¿Cómo es el dicho de Pablo Miranda
de la vaca?
El que se quema con leche ve a la vaca y llora.
Sí.
Me ha pedido a mí que Silmarín
ve a Rodrigo Mora y dice…
Yo en esta piedra no voy a volver a atropellar.
Son jugadores diferentes. Creo que tienen
mentalidad diferente.
Al final ha llovado. Podemos hablar de que le faltaba
x cosa física, que no ha sido otra cosa
pero la mentalidad parecía diferente.
Pero bueno, eso es algo que iremos viendo
con un Rodrigo Mora del que nos apetecía
hablar porque es muy posible que a pesar
de estas cositas se mueva en el mercado
de fichajes.